I hate this place I can barely
hurry up my face
now there's one place I'd much rather be
taken
Transfiguration and ER it MC
and with my friends
learning parts of speech and trying not
to fall asleep
better boarding the only girl school
it's so grotesque when the guy sitting
next to me trolls all over his desk and
I almost read my hand to complain
doing the same so I put my head down on
my desk as well
hence well
Danny with the up and I can't help but
yeah
oh this isn't Hogwarts this is a
concrete box the pictures on the wall
are never gonna talk and the teachers
don't care that the kids don't strive
and look magical thing we have as far as
the flight then open to and Hufflepuff
if you're not cool instead they sort you
in the parking lot after school and I
think if I looked into the mirror of
Erised said I ain't wearing wizard robes
with gold and red
I'm saying I'm not proud to be a nerd
the public school is no place for a
wizard at public school and a place for
a wizard
you know what's gross
now on speed looks like three day old
soggy toast but I laid it anyway I
overheard this guy I hardly know calling
me a nerd so I cast them from zipper on
ham
I wish there were house elves making my
food
thing was perfectly spiced and the only
one being
who was the pole - yeah
eyes then here's what's true I do pretty
much anything that got a wizard school
I'd even call the Laura suffrage my
friend
I never had to go to gym again
my life
Oh ghosts stuck in the halls
or hanging in a bathroom stall
and the stairs don't move cuz there's no
stairs it
this isn't Hogwarts this is a concrete
box and the pictures on the wall are now
and the teachers don't care the kids
don't try and the magical thing we have
is Bar and the tides and they don't
between the humble puppeteer not rule
instead they Sochi in the parking lot
school I think if I looked into the
mirror of Erised I'd be wearing wizard
robes the gold and red
I'm saying I'm not proud to be a nerd
the public school you know play for a
wizard yeah public school and a place
for a wizard you don't want to take that
one that one is great I wrote that song
for three reasons one because I truly
believe the school system in this
country to be degrading quickly and I
think we could learn a few things from
Hogwarts - because today Harry Potter
and the half-blood Prince came out two
and three because it is very nearly the
third anniversary of Aussie Aussie
Aussie Aussie Aussie Akio deathly
hallows the song that kicked the
vlogbrothers into the mainstream
Katherine and I went to the midnight
showing of half-blood Prince last night
and it was awesome I saw nerdfighters
there thank you guys for hanging out
that was fun and there are also other
Harry Potter things going on today
there's a harry potter truth or fail so
you can test your mental Harry Potter
might guess hosted by none other than
Kristina Horner of the parcel maths and
the five awesome girls and speaking of
awesome girls in wizard rock bands also
lauren fairweather of the moaning
myrtles and i wrote and recorded a song
together and we just did the video for
that 9 out of time so I